well it's a it's a very difficult it's a
very difficult question and it's certain
it's very understandable that they could
be saying like what are you doing
telling us what to do look what you've
done and you know we won our you've had
your time in the Sun we want we want
ours is very it's very understandable
but it's also very important so I know I
think like the weather it's Gandhi or
Michael Jackson saying and I start with
the man in the mirror I think I think
it's really important that we we do our
thing and and lead by example the u.s.
is a very powerful country and and one
that can can change and one that can
lead and I'd really like to see us leave
and I think we're starting and and
hopefully that will help developing
countries see well there's another way
of doing things and hopefully they can
leapfrog and not sort of go through all
that it's a very challenging thing it's
a very understandable thing these other
countries want to achieve a lifestyle
that we've been living and so who are we
to really say so I think we have to
influence as much as much as we can and
and also lead by example it's have to
practice what we preach
you